I have no idea what to expect this
season and I don't mean that in the ooh
I'm interested in what's going to happen
next sort of way I mean that on a I
honestly don't know how the hell they're
going to tell 12 episodes worth of story
with what has just happened in season
two sort of way the last season's climax
felt definitive final claimactic pick
any assortment of words that indicate
finality and that would be it there is a
coming full circle with both Reagan and
mob's character acts respectively both
have grown tremendously and found their
footing in a good place at the very end
of the series if someone told me that
that was it at the end of season 2
that's all one wrote I would have
accepted it and called it a perfect
series but now I'm staring down the
barrel of something I don't know what to
anticipate from which on one hand is
exciting but on the other it makes me
wonder can one stick The Encore after
executing one of the best seasons of
anime I have ever seen only one way to
find out
[Music]
tonight
[Applause]
anxiety aside going into this more than
anything I was overcome with curiosity
how was one and this team working at
Studio bones going to make this final
season field final there has to exist
some emotional through line that gets
paid off so let's see what episode 1 has
to offer these Seasons normally start
off with a few Standalone episodes that
act as the building blocks or indicating
factors that point us to the general
direction of how this season is going to
conclude so let's see what's cooking in
these first two episodes something I
noticed rather quickly was the tonal
difference or contrast expressed between
these opening episodes from season 3 and
the opening episodes from season one in
those season 1 opening episode the focus
of the plot was to demonstrate how and
where mob was lacking in his life and
that just so happened to be pretty much
everywhere with the first episode itself
ending on a note that lingered with a
sense of longing for what he doesn't
have Friends season 3 on the other hand
opens with a collection of episodes
emphasizing just how that has changed
forcing us to reflect on the evolution
of of this character and the most
powerful aspect of this being he
transformed in ways that all of us have
the power to transform ourselves as I
pointed out in the beginning of this
review series within the first episode
itself mob felt very much like a side
character in his own show with him not
really showing up until many scenes and
character introductions later acting as
the mop for Reagan's mess with his
introduction to us in the very first
episode being from behind where he was
barely noticeable in the background of
his own show with the scene itself
specifically centered around him as he's
surrounded by all of his friends he's
made thanks to the brave choices he
stuck to I love stuff like this and the
substance of the episode itself only
further reflects why I love it career
path survey God I remember those and
good God Almighty I did not know what to
do ranked 190th which is very middle of
the road for that school apparently mob
sits nicely and doesn't really know what
he wants to do but all he does know is
that he wants to pursue his Crush we get
exposed to pretty much every other
adjacent character's overall academic
ranking the body Improvement Club all
looks like how you'd expect they've put
all of their time into their bodies and
their academic goals are either nothing
or are helped by the extracurricular
achievements in sports and Athletics
except for one I love how one of them is
randomly ranked second in the entire
school like or Year I'm not sure and
looking to become a vet that's just kind
of funny but all that aside I do relate
to this episode quite a lot I remember
succinctly at the age of 17 sitting in
my guidance counselor's office
completely stressed out of my mind when
she confronted me about not filling in
my forms for college yet truth is at 17
and well even at 25 I still didn't know
what it was that I wanted to do with my
life this is all to say that not knowing
what to put down for one of these future
forms in school is stressful and at
worst depressing and terrifying as I
praise at the end of episode 13 of
season 2. I was thrilled the series our
and Ma both found a place in Reagan's
business that helped them feel like
something worthwhile and the way this
episode builds and leans into this new
Dynamic was brilliant they encounter
enter a man professing that he has been
cursed by a spirit that has made his
life unsuccessful he attributes all of
his personal social and professional
failings to this spirit and while mob
and sarizawa exercised this Spirit
successfully both are left reeling after
this encounter as they can both see
themselves in the mistakes this man has
made this man is in his 50s sarizawa is
30 and MOB is still in school but
looking at this man offers them a mirror
or future projection to how their lives
might be if they don't make the right
decisions from here on in and this is
where mob demonstrates profound levels
of growth as a character once again and
really this aspect of his character is
where the focus is placed in these
opening episodes while the first few
episodes of season 1 demonstrated fairly
basic areas of mob's life where he was
severely lacking these episodes offer
far more understandably complicated and
difficult social situations and
professional circumstances where many
people might find difficulty but mob
somehow finds a way out of it thanks to
his mindset the most interesting of
which episode one concludes with and
this conclusion mob reaches concerns
comfort and One's Choice is dictated by
that the idea that Comfort isn't
necessarily a goal one should seek but
rather the enemy of personal development
and progress is a wonderfully mature and
profound way of looking at things for
someone as young as he is and because of
this mob has to make decisions he
otherwise isn't comfortable with because
they are what's best for him that he
must eventually step away from Reagan
and his company with his reason being
the only thing that would change about
him if he were to stay there be his age
and the best part is there's no hard
feelings and Reagan supports mob's
decision is
somewhat confusingly the episode ends
with dimples sitting atop a giant piece
of broccoli that was in The Arc prior uh
this doesn't make any sense in context
but we'll no doubt in a few episodes or
so episode 2 in the same fashion as
episode 1 acts as a standalone episode
that serves to emphasize the growth of
mob again more specifically his ability
to speak up for himself his ability to
lead and prioritize problems that he has
despite it being inconvenient to others
he's able to put himself first which is
great for everyone to learn the episode
itself sees mob accept the job of a
costume or prop designer for a school
day of sorts all the wild Reagan humor
is the silly antics of some
self-professed Yokai Hunter
um okay naturally this doesn't interest
Reagan until a massive amount of money
becomes involved to which Reagan begins
speaking in a theatrical fashion just
like the Yokai Hunter it's hilarious and
fun specifically when the yokai's
eventually do show up however there is
one thing that's a little weird about
this place uh there's like these weird
roots and Vines growing everywhere um I
don't know whatever I'm sure it's
nothing they take out the Yokai King
easily and in the process of doing so
mob solved his own problems without the
help of Reagan which is again another
wonderful little development in the end
the work mob and his team did for a
school wasn't exactly praised but it
felt rewarding because they liked it and
they knew they had worked hard to make
it now before I dive into the minutia of
the next four episodes which make for
themselves a very compelling and well
thought out mini Arc I'd like to discuss
a rather large change that's taken place
on the production side of things for
this season 3 specifically during my
breakdown of the production for the
prior two seasons of the series
tachikawa was a series director in
addition to being super Hands-On
throughout those Seasons unfortunately
during the production of this final
season he was busy directing an anime
called Blue Giant and so a new series
director was brought in called takahiro
hasui hasui has been with Studio bones
since 2012 and directed the sixth
episode of mob psycho in season two so
he's not a complete Outsider by any
means but this is the first time he's
ever led a TV series interestingly
however while tachikawa was working on
another Pro he did remain somewhat
working on the series in a more
hands-off supervisory role though
outside of offering a small bit of
storyboarding in episode 10 his main
contribution was taking on a scripting
role writing episode 7 and 8 of this
final season which isn't too strange
seeing as he also wrote episode 6 and 7
in season 2. now I thought this was
worth mentioning right off the bat
because it's not often you see directors
of adapted Works writing scripts and
moving on from those broad Strokes
however the first episode is both
boarded and directed by hasui himself so
it's nice to get a sense right away of
how suitable he is for this role the
answer is uh very mob psycho 100 is such
a special series to these people because
it's all about elevating its source
material taking fun ideas from one's
manga and extrapolating cool new set
pieces from them right in the first half
of this episode Reagan fixing something
with rice is turned into a hilariously
dramatic action move in the anime it's a
simple change but one that lets me
breathe a sigh of relief over the
demonstration that this still feels very
much like mob through and through within
the first episode also we have returning
character animator toshiyuki Sato
animating a very common-esque sequence
of Reagan along with koki Fujimoto of
Chainsaw man Fame who produced this
fantastic scene that feels like a nice
parallel to a similar season 1 sequence
and it's certainly not the only
reference in this episode either
concerning episode 2 however hasui's
storyboards once again we get to see his
skills as an action storyboarder this
time around and I was very curious to
see the results of this and these
results are pretty damn competent tying
together characters and the environment
in ways we've come to expect from this
series you can see this throughout in
these stunning sequences that showcase
awesome background animation which as I
mentioned during my breakdowns of
previous seasons is but one of the many
common elements of mob's animation in
its series that does not make use of CGI
overall the second episode for me was
one that definitely solidifies hatsui as
a great successor tatachikawa however as
I'm sure you'll notice as I talk about
what else this season has to offer
what's probably the most fascinating
aspect about this season is that it
completely breaks the mold of a typical
anime production as I mentioned in the
previous videos mob Cycles production
always had a strong production
environment often finishing its
production before the final episode airs
but season 3 was different this time the
entire season was completed before even
the first episode hit the air this is
almost unheard of now with that said
however this season isn't as action
driven as the prior to nor is it quite
as ambitious due to many of its former
animator Associates being busy elsewhere
but a conservative season by mob psycho
100 standards is still light years ahead
of most other shows and despite this
talent pool change there are plenty of
returning stars to continue to shine Mio
Sato returns once again with her
incredible paint on glass animation
throughout the season and she even takes
on the ending sequence herself something
she also wowed us with back in season
one I have so much more to say about
this production but I'll leave it here
for now time to move on to the next and
first mini Arc of this final season the
Divine tree right off the bat I just
want to say that this mini Arc is my
favorite part of mob psycho thus far I
liked it better than the climax to both
the previous arcs and I shall intend on
explaining why in this preceding section
but in short it's a rather
straightforward story with nuances and
interesting areas for the involved
characters taking them in directions
we've not yet seen before in this series
to date all told within the context of
broccoli zombies you heard me right
Brock zombies this is the best Arc of
all time
these are really cute but short scene
that kicks off this episode and indeed
this mini Arc to a large extent where
mob actually has a positive interaction
with tsubomi without embarrassing
himself and indeed impressing tsubamey
by coming to her social rescue the point
of this successful interaction once
again is to act as a contrast to the
horrible interactions he's had in the
past all the while shining a light on
the blossoming social life he now has
with a number of girls in his school
with that reality suddenly Paving the
way for a very different set of
circumstances to be fallen Bob back
being he is popular how can you blame
him but the tearful Pride relief and
happiness ritsu has for his older
brother speaks for itself he knows how
he struggles socially and to see that no
longer be the case must be a massively
uplifting sight for him it's such a
wonderfully tender moment but it isn't
without certain drawbacks
thank you
hilariously on the nose visual metaphors
aside mob does get a big head over this
concerning his Newfound popularity and
this could not come at a worse time
because it's also the time the cold
surrounding Bob has mobilized around the
giant broccoli to worship it and moments
later dimple shows up and says to mob
his popularity has gone to his head and
confronts him about the founder of the
new religion audition and dimpled true
to Fashion tries to weasel his way into
the conversation but Bob sees through it
and maybe his ego allows him to believe
he doesn't need dimple's help at all
mob's confidence is turning into
overconfidence and that's when Bob
confronts dimple with a pointed question
is more
foreign
Ed meetings with mob and female friends
later and one bad t-shirt purchase we
find that despite Bob having decided to
go onto the podium to audition for the
position of founder since mizato bailed
on him Bob did go but curiously someone
looking just like mob arrived at the
podium to wow the audience this is where
the plot of this mini Arc starts to ramp
up and things really start to become
mysterious as Reagan watches from the
comfort of his own home on Livestream
this supposed founder sprouting before
everyone in the audience a giant
broccoli stock the next day yields a lot
of suspicious activity both mizato and
Tomo who they were both meant to meet
Bob the day prior now are suddenly all
in with this new religion but in
addition to that have no memory of why
they bailed on the respective arranged
meetings with mob in the first place but
once Reagan shows mob the clip online
mixed with the strange goings-on on the
town being slowly infested with these
mysterious roots not to mention those
weird new broccoli green candies people
are together for free everywhere the
true nature of what's actually happening
starts to form a clearer image they need
to destroy that broccoli and MOB agrees
in the midst of all this craziness Taro
has his own little adventure with the
brainwashing broccoli plant the section
itself is really well directed and
there's a heavy emphasis on the smaller
details in the day-to-day that I really
enjoyed the openings of fridges the slow
rise of someone's head to look up or
even the use of a mundane vending
machine all these subtle details that
are given extra attention really help to
ground the episode no pun intended but
more broadly this section really more
than anything else just serves to expose
us to the real enemy of this section and
what we can come to expect from him and
his goals vomiting up the food that he
had just been brainwashed with tarot
investigates the giant plant in an
effort to put an end to all of this
craziness but through doing so get
sucked into a terrifying fight against
this broccoli mob figure the fight
between the two is rather great but once
again this section really serves
primarily to expose us to the necessary
details of this character that we're
encountering right now to show us what
this being strengths and Powers truly
are while cutting away to other
characters like minigishi who grabs the
roots draining the city and falls to the
floor unconscious as a result and as the
Fight Continues with tarot It's Finally
Revealed that all of this has been
dimpled all along dimple is the founder
the spirit who formulated all of this he
says that mob doesn't matter that he's
always had one goal and that will be to
become a modern God ooh the plot
suddenly just became so much more
interesting a foundational character now
playing a key role in an adversarial
position and cut away to mob and Reagan
formulating a plan they think that they
might need help with this and so sea of
ritsu will help when in actuality he's
actually brainwashed and just guides
them to more followers in the whole
today except this new religion too
needless to say mob and Reagan just run
away and as of right now it's really
starting to feel like the entire city is
pursuing them like there's no one left
in their right mind I and feeding into
this very notion is a brilliant piece of
character writing between mob and Reagan
when Reagan catches mob calling the
founder fake now this is a very
important thing for him to call him out
on Reagan says that that's a very
strange thing to say seeing as the group
didn't have a Founder in the first place
and this is so subtle and while it does
go on to be revealed that Reagan is also
brainwashed by The Wacky plan too it's
also evident that something far more
subtle is at the root of all of this
mob's ego the same ego that pushed
dimple away to perform this mess but
needless to say mob doesn't accept
anything Reagan says of course and
tearfully runs away to set this whole
situation straight with heroic music
booming in the background he begins to
step towards the Divine tree he's going
to save everyone and Visually this is
communicated by him stepping out of the
Shadows no longer hiding and asking for
free entry to the person who so
feverishly in the past begged him to do
just that people Rejoice that they now
have two Founders to me and all the gym
Bros watch on this tree and dimple have
infected the minds of the entire city
this is where things really start to get
mind [__] and this Fanfare mob is
experiencing this clapping and cheering
all from Dimple and strangely it
contrasts harshly against what he said
the episode prior that he doesn't need
mob anymore well if he's trying to feed
into mob's ego here to manipulate him
why is he doing so if he doesn't need
him he shows him tarot restrained and
claims that ritsu and Reagan are under
his influence too with the explosion
counter in mob Rising he even draws
attention to what he made Reagan say
that in the end the ones who have the
most fun win foreign
foreign
dimple tries to convince mob to join him
explaining that everyone in the city and
everyone he ever knew is under his
control now I think it's safe to say
that dimple within this series is one of
the few characters who can claim that
they know mob really is and how he
thinks what his weaknesses are and what
he can do to exploit just that and he
does so through uncertainty and it's
quite unsettling he forces tarot to
fight mob trying to confuse mob by
leveraging the lesson he tried to tell
Terror back in season one not to use his
powers for his own self-interest and all
of this makes even me as an audience
member feel unsure and unsettled as a
result but mob he sticks to his
convictions because he isn't the same
kid that was in season one exploding
with power sending Teru flying more of
these broccoli monsters start to show up
and subdue mob as his explosion meter
Rises dimple still refusing to show
himself despite being called upon by mob
refusing to face him is he scared well
mob Falls the floor after clutching his
chest his power is being sucked away
dimple is now all-powerful deciding at
this moment now to appear before Mom but
interestingly despite finding him the
vast majority of his time is spent still
trying to convince him over to his way
of thinking
just a quick aside for a second the
animation for this transformation and
indeed this form reminds me so much of
frieza's transformation into golden
Frieza everything from the form itself
to even the reveal animation the
swooping Grand angles feel very freezer
but also really help to sell what dimple
is doing here dimple is combining
everything he knows about mob to defeat
him draining him of the max energy he
demonstrated during the fight against
toichiro Suzuki alongside the Mind Games
he learned from mugami through the lens
of someone mob thought of as a friend no
less this is an interestingly evil
decision by dimple and an approach that
me sitting right here now watching has
me thinking damn this just might
actually work on both of these occasions
mob came close to losing to dying and
combining these approaches with a close
friend's underhanded attack it's more
likely to succeed than pretty much any
other approach that's been taken in the
series however in response to this mob
takes a different approach again
meow and I
dimple explodes with a massive attack
and regrets firing it with such energy
almost immediately by catching himself
but he says that he can still feel his
rage mob once more asks for dimple to
say something honest something authentic
but he doesn't and attacks one last time
I think given the fact that mob has been
the point of view character in this mini
Arc with him effectively trying to
figure out the mystery surrounding
dimple with his ever dwindling number of
allies it's then an interesting choice
to not have Bob himself be the POV
character of the climax but instead to
switch it over to Dimple once he reveals
himself or shown his internal thoughts
his strategies and his concerns as mob
creeps closer and closer to 100 and once
he does explode nothing happens because
we're still stuck only seeing the
thoughts of dimple were made to
empathize with him that little bit more
were confused just like him what is
happening and the monologue from Dimple
is quite telling he's confused but not
once practice on about his plans for
world domination he's not looking past
mob even in the slightest in fact he
seems more concerned about whether or
not he mob is given up on him that he's
resigned to giving up to turning this
fight into a half-assed Climax and I
think that more than anything else in
this Arc feels like a cry for help like
he wants mob to convince him and as
dimple threatens mob's Life One Last
Time with a sharp blade inches from his
face
mob says he won't do it by turning off
his powers Bob lays himself defenseless
and by doing so exposes dimple in return
both metaphorically and literally
pushing through his guard
foreign
the lesson here Harkens back to a number
of instances in this story reflected in
the words Reagan offered him in passing
about those who gain confidence usually
going too far before finding their
footing later and as mob admits
rightfully he didn't treat dimple with
the level of respect and care he needed
to he was at his most vulnerable through
this mob realizes the role he played all
the while seeing that the exact same
shortcoming and lesson befell dimple
they were two people going through the
same thing and by being such fed into
one another creating this mess we see
before us by hearing him out and
offering him what he's always truly
needed dimple is allowed to on his own
terms realize for himself that he has
more income with mob than he might have
ever even realized that just like him
all he has ever really wanted wasn't to
be a God or to be a leader or to be some
cult of personality but to be
acknowledged to be seen to have a real
friend that wants him for who he is and
nothing more and it makes sense that
manipulation is dimple's calling card in
this instance he doesn't trust anyone to
actually want to altruistically be his
friend and in giving dimple that time of
day mob saved everyone in the town and
indeed dimpled from himself it's a
brilliant story reaching a conclusion
with dimple carrying a defenseless and
sleeping mob back to his bed to rest
gonna
and suddenly
boy
this is such a cool idea made possible
with this world and its Unique Mechanics
but what in reality is happening here is
that dimple now has to face the
consequences of his actions alone
without the help of his support system
to do what makes him uncomfortable to do
something dangerous for someone else to
do the right thing the cycle helmet
wants mob for sustenance but dimple
refuses his advances here we have a
fight between the real dimple and the
part of him that he rejected his good
side versus his evil Tendencies and ah I
was so excited watching this the way
this broccoli doppelganger moves is even
spooky in and of itself like he's some
sort of evil spirit or Specter
impervious to the attacks of the real
world and In This Moment dimple is the
only one standing in defense of an
unconscious mob while staring down
hundreds of clones the file itself is
spectacular and comes with its own bells
and whistles we've come to expect from
this incredible series with dimples
slowly having to end energy drained by
his impressive foe but even outside of
that there's such an incredible sense of
scale to this fight the occasion is
Grand and the action surrounding it my
God it's stunning and then
the final scene takes place where from
the midst of this intense action we cut
to Dimple waking up mob he's unable to
stand but for the first time proper
dimple is able to use his powers to
manipulate Bob for his own good and
despite the goals he's espoused to have
in the past he chooses to let mob walk
out under his own power it's through
this brief interaction that dimple
acknowledges just how strong mob is and
as the seconds tick by we notice a
scratch on his cheek and more damage and
more damage as time passes on and as the
camera pans out slowly but surely we
recognize the damage that dimple himself
has taken and moreover that he's used
this power to lure mob home because he
knows he may never see him ever again
from such a heartfelt and uplifting
finish to their encounter one has
dragged us back to the pits of Despair
and sorrow as he reminds us of what
happens when we get too carried away
when we hurt too many people that those
consequences just might exact the
ultimate toll it's a crushingly
beautiful selfless heroic and sad scene
but when I am delighted dimple got to
have and as mob sits there lying in his
bed unsure of what exactly happened his
heart knows the truth and he cries
himself to sleep
this is the first major Action episode
of the season and was directed by Yuta
kiso having previously worked as an
animator on shows like my hero Academia
as a regular animator episode 6 is his
very first time directing an episode
proper and interestingly he's actually a
newcomer too mob psycho 100 series
having only contributed a small rather
unrecognizable section of season 2's
opening transitioning from an animator
to a director storyboard artist can be
rough but his work here is truly
remarkable not only does it nail the
action sequences with the most
Monumental scale possible it also
manages to execute the emotional moments
with real gravitas the animation staff
assembled for this episode is pure
All-Star material also and the results
speak for themselves I mean this does
not stop moving yoshimichi kameda takes
on the animation director role and along
with him there's the legendary Yutaka
Nakamura Yuki Hayashi hironori Tanaka
and many other All-Star names it really
is just the most ludicrous episode
nakamura's sequence is undeniably the
Highlight however of the the episode
with his trademark three-dimensionality
and dynamic lighting that just explodes
off the screen the scale here I have to
reiterate is off the charts Tanaka's
smoke is also insane and the snappy
timing feels very common to esque in its
execution helping these sequences blend
together nicely many people know Yuki
Hayashi for his Dragon Ball super Broly
work and his many contributions to my
hero Academia and he's here too pulling
off the same craziness with arguably the
most weighty scene in the episode
there's a quality to this work that's
hard to put into words it never loses
its sense of exaggeration despite how
much grounded oomph it conveys the big
emotional finale with wonderful lip sync
however hasn't had its animator
identified yet but it's one of those
scenes that jumps into realism in a way
that really grabs your eyes and
emphasizes the emotional weight of the
scene
the telepathy Club Arc these are the
episodes that convince me that this
story could focus on just about any of
The Supporting Cast and still deliver
superb storytelling that captures my
attention and Imagination perfectly I
love these characters and on this
particular occasion it's graduation time
entrance exams for some private schools
will start soon and unlike the last mini
Arc which Focus largely on Mob himself
this one more specifically focuses on
the insecurities of Tomei and The Wider
telepathy Club as they struggle to face
a difficult reality that they may just
have wasted all their times goofing off
instead of working on themselves or
building memories in this club taking it
seriously this is a very interesting
idea and direction to build on the story
we've seen mob focus on the body
Improvement club for these very reasons
and in this moment we see the rest of
the club sort of come to grips with that
lesson with the very Growing Pains of
this realization acting as the impetus
for this entire mini Arc
foreign
this is the indirect call to action for
the rest of the club to try and help
Tomei not feel as though she's a total
failure to help her once and for all
make real strides towards her goal that
she created this club for to meet Aliens
now naturally something like that would
seem completely unreasonable in any
other sort of story but let's not forget
that this is Mob psycho 100's world we
are talking about a story where the main
character can hurl buildings while
crying and a magical giant head of
broccoli can brainwash thousands and so
naturally inukava one of the other boys
from the telepathy Club employs the help
of mob who employs the help of ritsu who
eventually employs the help of those two
uh no come on come on you can do it I
believe in you what were their names
oh uh the Twins daichi and kaito who
could forget them anyway Jokes Aside
while the stakes are comparatively low
compared to those that occupied much of
season 2 the fact that this contends
more personally with the characters
we've all come to know and have grown
attached to it actually feels all the
more important as a result of that I was
so damn invested in how they were going
to resolve some of these seemingly
unsolvable problems how would they
attract the attention of a real telepath
and not a crappy one like these guys
well as it happens they can send a
signal to attract other telepaths and
MOB can boost that signal which creates
one of the coolest twists and creative
choices of the entire season
dada
[Music]
um
takanaka the guy who left the club in
episode 2 of season freaking one answers
the call I cannot describe to you how
damn cool this Choice was creatively not
only is it a callback that sent me
reeling but he's showing up and initial
departure are all linked to the
underlying themes and journey of this
story the reason he left in the first
place is because they clearly weren't
serious like he was about understanding
telepathy and the club itself but as
soon as they start to show that level of
seriousness and compassion they created
for themselves the perfect set of
circumstances to bring him specifically
back into the fold this is terrific
storytelling and character writing on
all one and even some Advanced [__] it
is awesome and the icing of the cake is
Mob breaks through his wall too finding
common ground with him coming from a
place of isolation also and guess what
takanaka because he's a telepath knows
that mob isn't lying to him I love stuff
like that and this was by far the best
scene of the episode
foreign
this scene is hilarious and if you know
you know I ain't explaining why the plan
however is to drive to a mountain go to
the top of it and give Thoma her
telepathy experience with Reagan
agreeing to tag along and drive with the
ultimate goal being to use takanaka to
make contact with aliens using mob as a
signal booster as they make their way up
the mountain enjoying setbacks both
mentally and geographically I just have
to point out that the direction of this
episode is absurdly stunning and on
another level compared to pretty much
every other episode I've seen up until
now and you best believe I'll be talking
about exactly this in the production
section for this episode in just a
moment but regarding the narrative
there's a moment with takanaka that once
again highlights that one knows exactly
where to put the focus in his stories
and that place is the heart and emotion
of a particular scene and really more
than anything else that's the calling
card of this particular artist it's why
despite the crude drawings at times
billions of people read his work more
than just this incredible Direction I
praised earlier it's the heartfelt and
tender message that this episode offers
takanaka cared so much about this and
Thomas experience that he dedicated his
entire night to learning and researching
everything he needed to for today
explaining away his lateness earlier in
the episode which was a brilliant touch
it's just such a touching Revelation
with the very ritual that takes place
itself acting as a wonderful prelude for
all of us to take a lesson from
adventuring outside of our comfort zone
and putting in effort with friends to
achieve and try something is not only
fun but can change our lives create
memories and more importantly can change
your outlook in life however shockingly
they do make contact with aliens I love
how Toma is so nervous that she reaches
out to shake their hand with the wrong
hand to do so with it's such a subtle
detail but for me really went a long way
in visually communicating how nervous
and really important this moment was for
her needless to say they have a great
time hanging out with the aliens and
playing games like they did in their
homeroom almost like all that time
wasn't wasted after all and yet despite
all that's going on Reagan's mind is on
the passage of time the New Year late
fees on his rental he looks at this
group of kids and says that they are
quote blinding almost like their future
is all ahead of them and looks promising
and I'm of course just inferring this
but when you take into account his
relationship with his mom what she's
been writing to him and what little he
shared about his past it all seems to
point in the direction perhaps also
alluding to him not feeling fulfilled in
his life I mean he's very much the
proverbial extra wheel in this group of
children while having himself no plans
for New Year's anyway with that said
they all exchange gifts with the aliens
before leaving except a new Kawa who
accidentally stays and gets abducted
more on that in just a second at Tomei
is thrilled with her experience and says
it's a new year she will never forget
this was a a really nice serious oddly
introspective and emotionally mature
mini Arc centered around a group that
represented exactly the opposite of that
in the series and really that's perfect
because this episode is four people that
feel like that the end of school Life as
we know it is a formative period for
anyone and to see this story leverage
that common aspect of all of our Lives
to help tell this captivating and
heartwarming tale is just so powerful
production the one the only hakuyogo
returns to completely blow mines once
again in a distinct flavor unlike
anything we've yet seen from him and it
is breathtaking goes head-turning
episodes have previously been huge
action climaxes and yet this is an
episode with no such fighting or action
and one that proves more importantly
that ghost versatility knows no limits
as an artist and I'm referring to him as
an artist and not simply as an animator
here because much like his episode on
season 2 this is all from a single mind
he takes on the role of Direction
storyboarding and animation Direction
meaning everything you see in this
episode is go through and through his
animation Direction here is incredibly
striking doing away with model sheet
adherence in favor of Blobby loose
characters with almost no shading and
very distinctive rounded hair displaying
a constant striking approach that
extends throughout the episode entirely
and is truly emblematic of how mob's
production environment is Creator first
its artistic Freedom has been a defining
part of its success and it really is on
Full display here it truly cannot be
overstated also however just how
animated this episode is and feels when
talking about other episodes I've
definitely said this does not stop
moving which is a bit of hyperbole to
emphasize the insanity that is the
quality of the animation across the
episodes but that statement applies with
no hyperbole whatsoever right here it
genuinely does not stop with its
ludicrous character animation for its
entire runtime it is one of the most
insane Feats I've ever seen committed to
an episode of its type and the painful
thing is I'm sure a lot of people
typically would notice this because it
isn't an action episode there's such a
grounded approach to the animation that
believe it or not it is not rotoscoped
in any way also you have foreign
animators like Julian Bentley producing
insane work of characters simply walking
there's crazily detailed shots that have
no reason to be as good as they are such
as Reagan taking his shirt off like that
is insane and it's a background element
it just goes on and on walk Cycles from
super hard angles fully fleshed out
cities and crowd shots it is
breathtaking through and through and on
the topic of talking about crazy
animation sakuka this episode also has
what is as close as you can get to music
sakuga if that makes any sense at all
starting at 1646 the entire back third
of the episode is one contiguous
dedicated piece of music not something
that you see live literally anywhere
else in general let alone kawaii's mob
psycho 100 score and honestly this
creative Choice has me perplexed maybe
one could argue that it gives this
entire section of the episode a rather
alien feel to it not that it sounds
alien but that it feels alien to have
this one big piece of music over an
entire third of an episode unbroken I
mean that big track does transition from
largely Earthly textures like strings
and Woodwinds to more alien sounding
instruments like synth patches once we
do get to the final scene detailing
inukawa's adventures in outer space and
then as if the episode itself wasn't
enough of a flex it throws in a crazy
alien jungle sequence animated to
Perfection by Yuki Hayashi once again
and ajin and on the topic of this
closing section it reminds me tachikawa
scripted this episode and features some
major changes to the manga in manga many
chapters famously end with Omak stories
that are not present in the anime
generally speaking but interestingly in
the manga some of these actually expand
on character backgrounds that are not
present in the anime like the welcome
kids for example which got that added
bit of attention in the manga but for
these particular omakas at the end of
the telepathy Club story kachikawa used
them to produce the strangest and yet
greatest sequence in the series
inukawa's Abduction the manga section of
this plays out as a regular gag manga
ending abruptly at the moment where they
come back to earth and realize that they
can't find inukawa that's the punchline
that's the joke that's the end of it
then during the next few chapters of the
mob conclusion story were presented with
the omake known as inukawa's diary every
chapter representing a different time
and experience from those abduction days
narrated by inukawa himself via a
journal he's writing and it's the same
Journal we saw in the anime but the
anime on the other hand takes all those
Omak pages and makes this weird crazy
somewhat unsettling and hilarious story
about inukawa's Misadventures in this
alien world it's an outstanding change
to the source material in my book and
one that totally enhances the material
the final Arc episodes 9 10 11 and 12.
say the line mark
this is the best Arc of mob psycho 100
by default and I say as much because it
utilizes literally every element and
every event that made the mob psycho 100
story what it is today this is a
storytelling Triumph and more than that
an utter Masterpiece Master stroke and
masterful work of art as everything from
the production to the narrative setup
and set pieces and even the music work
together with a unified vision of
bringing to life what is in my
estimation one of if not the best Arc of
Storytelling I've seen from an anime in
my life this is a special Story one near
and dear to my heart now and I hope that
while I break down why I think this is
so impressive you find something that
you too can take away from it so let's
dive in one of the many aspects that
makes this Arc so successful in my
opinion is how it leverages a
character's point of view to tell a
compelling story changing the point of
view of whose or narrative POV can be
interesting but changing povs can also
give us a clearer picture of the reality
at and divorced from the feelings of a
particular onlooker now that's a lot of
words what do I mean well for now let's
take a look at the focus of this episode
and indeed a big role player in this
final Arc subomi
this Arc is effectively about mob
mustering the courage to ask out
tsubamey before she transfers to a
different school and in the opening
moments of this Arc we see a dream mob
is having about her and him playing as
children it's nice it's warm and it's
Fantastical however when we contrast
that with the actual core memories he
has of her while he's awake you have for
yourself a very different outlook on the
scene and indeed her as a person
creating this sense that while she and
he were once close nowadays that doesn't
seem to be the case this is reinforced
musically around the nine minute Mark of
episode 9 where we hear the music that
was used for the alien investigation now
repurposed for the discussion between
mob and mizato concerning tsubomi
someone who is now foreign to both of
these folks talking in the scene but
what's more is that in this scene and
indeed later episodes again they begin
to show a very understated visual design
aspect of tsubamey that I could well
imagine went unnoticed by many people
watching this video and it's Unique to
the anime in the manga super depicted
with largely the same style all the
other girls have plain mostly regular
sized eyes crude eyelashes Etc but in
the anime she is the only female
character with traditionally anime
characteristics huge sparkly anime eyes
more traditional anime eye shapes thick
top eyelashes you know the stuff however
in this episode around the 9 Minute Mark
again a Keen Eye begins to notice that
how tsubami looks in the anime is
probably actually largely up to mob's
interpretation or fantasy of her through
his point of view and so when we see
tsubami from mizato's point of view in
this scene 9 minutes into the ninth
episode we see her depicted less
flatteringly with the bottom eyelashes
and smaller more traditional eyes later
in the finale too we see this even more
explicitly in this sequence of images
this little detail which is also a bit
of a retroactive explanation for her
played up anime design is brilliant in
my opinion and on the narrative front
the entire episode itself is basically
comprised of mob ass asking the advice
of the Litany of characters that have
made up this series for advice on how he
can approach asking to Bow me out and
honestly reika's advice is the best
piece he receives saying that while he
should keep all the advice he's received
in mind he shouldn't worry about
strategy or Keeping Up Appearances that
if subomi is the sort of girl love wants
a deep relationship with
she'll like him and be with him for who
he is and interestingly once mob leaves
he shares a rather Illuminating piece of
dialogue concerning his view of himself
he says If This Were me I'd probably
just try to be slick I mean if they
found out who I really was I'd get
rejected in an instant this was a line
that confirmed for me that my suspicions
concerning Reagan's self-esteem were
well founded near the end of this
episode mob decides to set up a meeting
with tsubame via a phone call and I
cannot imagine I was the only one who
with their heart in their stomach while
watching this hoping and praying that he
doesn't mess up too badly and I think
this is emphasized because for the
entire call there's virtually no music
just ambient noise from mob's house
there's an unusually heavy emphasis on
Folly here sounds of doors opening bags
rustling footsteps are all elevated
higher in the mix than they would
usually be a great call in my opinion as
it really heightens the tension of the
scene I think many of us have been there
on phone calls with significant others
or brushes when we were younger the
feeling is not unfamiliar The Silence of
almost everything but the words and the
sounds around them capture this sense of
tension we all know too well which
brings us to the faithful day where mob
makes his way to the park to meet subomi
and ask her out everyone he's met and
continues to meet seems to make this
process the best it can be all the
advice support and even flowers he's
given are all provided by people that he
has helped in the past surely this
encounter would be the same
this is the part of the story where we
realize that mob has one more demon to
exercise one more emotional hurdle to
overcome and when I say that this is one
of the best depictions of struggling to
accept who you are as a person I mean
that what unfolds from this point on is
utterly and dumbfoundingly incredible on
a narrative animation and even a musical
level no punches are pulled here and
just like the rest of the series the
entire crew and production behind this
entire series is firing on all cylinders
this is the final time we are introduced
to the character indicated by three
question marks mob has overcome a host
of difficult adversaries across this
series some stronger than others and
many which pushed him in complicated
existential and sometimes physical
methods the likes of which he only
barely made it out of those situations
alive characters like the members of
claw bogami toichiro to name only but a
few but today mob faces the individual
he's being the most fearful of
throughout this series The foe that is
the indirect source of mob's internal
traumas and indeed the main antagonist
of this entire series himself and who
can stop him
as an adaptation the reference of
question mark question mark question
mark after mob gets hit by a car is
handled quite differently in the manga
than it is in the anime once again it
becomes a question of Direction and
point of view here in other words what
we as an audience member are allowed to
see and understand the biggest
difference the manga offers here is that
we actually get to see much more of Bob
than we do in the anime in the anime
there's no dialogue for him and instead
we don't see him standing up and
destroying everything that gets in his
way instead you see the destruction
wrought on the city from Faraway Through
The Eyes of civilians the news and other
characters from the show personally I
really like this approach as it offers
this sense that someone else is behind
the wheel someone we don't know and by
keeping this distance the directors
indirectly position us as viewers to see
this as the act of a Mindless monster
causing destruction around him out of
pure Instinct in other words we get the
distinct impression that this isn't the
kagayama shigayo that we all know and
love the manga however takes a very
different approach and honestly there's
mayor to this direction too there's this
ominous feeling from him when he wakes
up he talks for the very first time and
what he says tells us right away that
this is in fact not kagayama shigayo
this is the moment of Confirmation and
in the anime this is presented much
later during an inner monologue between
the two of them when you already know
the identity of the power that he is
part of our mob a part that he kept
hidden from everybody you realize that
shigayo and MOB might as well be two
separate identities at odds in his mind
and this was when you might think that
those three question mark symbols on his
percentage name could instead represent
three missing letters
m-o-b personally I prefer the approach
taken in the anime it positions us as
fans to receive the swerve later on in a
much more effective fashion in my
opinion and moreover feeds into this
narrative Direction the Story will be
taking from this point on that mob is in
trouble and whoever this is needs to be
stopped I think from a structural
standpoint the most impressive aspect
narratively or one of them at least is
that of who is chosen this stand in the
way of the Rogue mob and why and to
those that didn't catch it this might be
a pretty neat little observation I've
made as I mentioned for the longest time
mob has been terrified of this exact
situation occurring a traumatic concern
born from a lifetime of feeling like he
has no control past a certain point a
Breaking Point we've been shown a number
of times throughout this story what
instances during this story did he break
who did he break in front of Teru koyama
toichiro ritsu all of the people who in
that order stand in his way one after
the other in this very Arc those that
are once acted as the reason to draw
this entity out of him are now standing
on the other side of the field looking
to do the exact opposite to help mop to
save him to put this Genie back into the
bottle and through these individual
clashes what's highlighted isn't how
Adept they are necessarily or how strong
they have become or even how they lose
but instead how different they are to
the last time they faced each other
other morally ethically and personally
it's a frankly perfect narrative choice
in my opinion Teru vs Mob if I'm being
honest of the upcoming fights I
mentioned this is the one that received
most of the attention from an animation
standpoint on the visual front there are
a lot of comparisons made to the first
fight instead of fighting for ego taru
is fighting for the right reasons
instead of putting other innocent people
in danger he saves them directly and
defends them with his dying breaths he
even gets his clothes melted away again
this time not because he's obstinent or
big-headed but because he's courageously
standing in front of a hurricane of
psychic energy hoping that if he can
just hold on he can make a difference he
can save up despite the blood leaving
his eyes his shield shattering or his
skin burning he wants to save mob he
wants to save everyone ultimately he
doesn't succeed but he does succeed in
showing how much of a radical change his
character has undergone in the last
three seasons and he saves an enormous
amount of people in the process
koyama versus mob of the four encounters
mob squares off against this is the
least impactful and striking in my
opinion in fact most of it is shown off
camera however something worth
discussing is that koyama now has made
something of himself that is honest no
longer working as the muscle for a
criminal Syndicate now he manages and
operates out of a small shop and instead
of trying to antagonize someone in this
situation he's very much on the
defensive but perhaps most miraculously
despite there being a tremendous amount
of damage being done despite Sirens
blaring and despite evacuation notices
being issued subami is actually waiting
in the Park from up despite being
surrounded by all the chaos she still
Waits now that is either stupid or
immensely honorable and willing to give
her the latter but they aren't
necessarily mutually exclusive either I
suppose toichiro vs bomb toichiro's
battle or confrontation with mob while
getting a substantial amount of flair
via some great animation also has a
brilliantly appropriate and resonant
conclusion when the I think we need to
see more of in these kinds of series
toichiro's goal here is to try and save
mob the same way he did for him he tries
to use his power to absorb Bob's energy
and closes the Gap making it a war of
attrition but even then mob is so
savagely powerful more powerful than he
could ever hope to be and even with the
added support of his son show they still
aren't anywhere near strong enough to
put an end to this here and now this is
where toichiro knows he has only one
option left to take op down and to put
an end to this and in identifying this
option he shows just how much he's
changed since the end of that second
season
foreign
would have just indulged in a simple and
rather vapid sacrifice but this is an
incredibly mature and moving decision
one that honestly has stayed with me
longer than that vapid sacrifice could
ever have been deciding instead to flee
with his son valuing what he has a
second shot at cherishing henceforth
ritsu versus mob more than anything else
this moment really serves to provide us
with Exposition for Mob psyche
Exposition for the very first time mob
lost it in other words the inciting
incident that led to this entire story
and Ma being the way that he is someone
who hates who he is deep down Ritu says
that he used to be scared of this form
thinking that it was a different version
of mob altogether but now I think he
understands that he was wrong that it's
the same older brother that he's always
loved that it's a part of him and the
reason he's so destructive is due to mop
himself not being accepting of that part
of him and it turns out that those times
that ritsu went to mob and asked if he
wanted to talk about things that they
all came from that very day and mob's
sudden shift in character he wanted
power so that he could be ready for this
moment to be here for his brother but
despite his best efforts he can't stop
Bob it's from this moment on Bob
continues to walk and he suddenly become
privy to a conversation or conflict
taking place in his mind where there is
a terrific visual metaphor for exactly
what is taking place it's here we
realize that that side of mob that part
that's been locked away it isn't
necessarily bad just suppress beneath
years of trauma and now it's exploding
ready to take control and to never give
it back again and it's at this point in
time I think we realize that only one
person can stop
despite being the final part of this
final Arc I wanted to separate this
episode from the rest because I think
it's just that important not just in the
context of the story with it providing
everything I wanted and more but also
because this is a conclusion that
teaches a very valuable lesson everyone
I think at one point or another in their
lives needs to learn my grandparents
never learned this lesson and many
adults haven't learned this lesson and
growing up as a teenager and even a
young adult when I should have I didn't
learn this lesson which I think made
this episode and finale all the more
powerful and personal powerful because
it is a terrific story to tell in every
sense of the word personal for reasons
I'll be getting into in just a moment as
I'm sure you've noticed in this
three-part series I love to explore what
the music in the story can offer its
narrative how it can frame a scene and
in some cases what it can tell us about
the story it's housed within this
episode does just that and reveals to us
the hidden meaning of its third opening
theme and indeed the theme of season 3
as a whole the entire song and its
chorus are all about the internal
struggle of mob and this unidentified
entity he has to Grapple with inside
with the resolution of this season being
Bob accepting his other half and
becoming I'm an only one which makes it
all the more interesting that the insert
song for this season wasn't that track
but instead 99 the op from the very
first season and the answer to why that
is the case becomes clear when you look
at what it represents in context each of
the opening tracks for these three
seasons represents something important
to the material covered in that section
referring to mob for the most part as I
mentioned the opening for season 3
offered a subtle hint towards necessary
changes Bob needed to make that he needs
to accept that we are who we are and
that just because you don't like a part
of yourself that doesn't mean that that
part isn't necessarily bad or not a part
of you that you need to make an effort
not to tear yourself apart and hide away
that you need to present yourself not as
a person of compartmented sections but a
person that is just as the song says one
and only one the second opening's main
message is to communicate to mob that he
needs to get ready to achieve his goals
and to remind him in no uncertain terms
that he shouldn't be beholden to anyone
that he should treat himself with
respect and not as someone else's
doormat to remind him and indeed all of
us that your life is your own no one
else's which brings me to the insert
song used in this final episode the
first opening of the entire series
otherwise known as 99 this is my
personal favorite of the three tracks
and it's the initial and first major
lesson Bob learns on his long quest for
self-acceptance so if the goal of this
Arc is echoed by the words one and only
one from the third op and this scene
deals with the resolution of that
mission statement for Mob accepting
himself for who he is why are we hearing
99 the season 1 OPI well because this
scene isn't shown from the point of view
of Bob but instead Through The Eyes of
Reagan and this is what makes this song
choice and this scene so intensely
powerful and resonant for me I've
alluded to this countless times across
this review series that Reagan has while
taking advantage of mob and those that
seek his help through manipulation
disease he's also living a life that he
isn't proud of or satisfied with while
this Series has indeed been about mob
and his growth emotionally and
physically we've also been offered
fleeting glimpses behind the curtain of
the Reagan character himself we've heard
concerning anecdotes from his childhood
about how he never joined any clubs
seeing his mother's scathing emails of
embarrassment towards her own son and of
course A Feeling expressed by Reagan
himself that he may have felt like he
missed the train to becoming the person
he always wished he could be and
speaking as someone that never really
felt like he had Direction in life that
felt terrified to let people in growing
up and even lied to friends and family
to hide who I was Reagan more than mob
or any other character has emotion
emotionally connected with me I was
scared to be who I was in high school I
did what I thought was socially
acceptable by going to college but
pushing in that direction just led me to
being overworked tired exhausted and
dropping out in my third year I hated it
following that unable to deal with the
reality I stopped visiting my friends
who were all graduating college and
getting great jobs I couldn't face them
I took up a job in a liquor store and
just sort of forgot about it all and for
years it was that way and I've never
explained this story in a video before
but I used to be really into
professional wrestling the WWE were not
the Olympic wrestling one I thought that
since I was a fan for over a decade that
I knew what it took and I figured one
day it could be cool to pursue it as a
career to train super hard and travel to
America to audition
and I trained I trained hard I trained
for two years straight and put on a
great deal of muscle in the process I
took lessons and classes in both my city
and on the other side of my country that
I would travel to every week on a
rickety bus all without my friends or my
family knowing I put this work in and
then right as I was about to leave for
America I had to tell my parents and
I'll never forget what my dad said to me
I'll never forget it because it was the
moment I proved to myself that I wasn't
who I wished I was he said Son I've
never asked you not to do anything
before but please for the love of God
don't do this and I could hear the
embarrassment in his voice when he was
saying this to me after years of telling
myself that I had changed that I had
found what I wanted to do and after
making the plan and sticking to it for
years I listened to him and I gave up
and to this day I've never been able to
watch wrestling again this is all of
course to say that it's easy to identify
that one ought to do something in a
given situation but it takes a much
stronger person to have the conviction
to stick to what they sought out to
accomplish in the first place and at 23
years of age I proved to myself that I
wasn't who I thought I was I proved to
myself that I was the same shy kid who
couldn't stand up for himself or be
proud of who he was that moment still to
this day haunts me and honestly I don't
think I'd be in the position I am now
without it because of that decision I
made when I decided that I wanted to
pursue another unconventional job in
YouTube and my dad didn't understand
that either when he came to me and had
that same talk I was able to then prove
to myself that I had those convictions
that I was missing before and I was able
to do that because at that point I knew
how painful it was to take the easy way
out and do as he said admitting to
yourself you were a liar that you were a
coward and that you lacked conviction to
make your dreams a reality is a horrible
existential pill to swallow and that's
what made me cry when I was watching
this and it's why this song was perfect
for Reagan a 28 year old man having not
achieved anything in school a man who
specializes in lying and scamming people
now has to take a series of terrifying
steps both metaphorically and literally
[Music]
instead of letting his fear of himself
take over Reagan reveals that he's been
training that he won't let mob win that
he will for Mob and for him reach him no
matter the risks no matter the fear no
matter what might happen and as the
hurricane of lyrics crash around him
counting his each and every step
eventually the song crescendos and in
that moment Reagan learns the first
lesson he helped to teach mod in season
one that if everyone's not special maybe
he could be what he wants to be it's the
perfect song choice for a 28 year old
man running to catch up with his dreams
of being the person he always wished he
could have been and while he still
doesn't know if he can be that person
he's willing to take that first step and
tell mob the truth
despite being an emotional mess with my
vision obscured by a tidal wave of tears
at this point I did manage to notice
that despite his best efforts mob still
wasn't willing to listen and that's when
the single best reveal in the series
happens
interestingly and quite fittingly the
first time mob uses two hands against
someone is against Reagan and dimple and
I think that's a really nice touch and
what's more is if you remember from my
review of season 2 my only criticism of
the season was that it felt like the two
pivotal climaxes of the series had taken
place at two different points well this
final season remedies all of that ending
with two climaxes to the two biggest
acts of the series delivering an
emotional gut punch the likes of which
left me despondent in the best of ways
after viewing I don't say this often but
this climax this Arc this season this
story is perfect in every sense of the
word I could not in any way change
something to make it better this is a
series that needs to be seen by everyone
this climax this confession this
reconciliation is the scene and moment
that mob psycho 100 has been building up
towards a place where two characters
with effectively the exact same problem
dealing with it in totally different
ways come together to help each other
mob lies to himself about who he is and
Reagan lies to others about who he is
both coming from a place of
self-loathing and insecurity mob through
his powers and Reagan not seeing himself
as worthy of anyone's time if he were to
reveal who he was actually and what
makes this scene so special is that
together they provide the other the key
the answer to what they've been looking
for all along again this is just a
perfect scene and a perfect show
[Music]
in the end mob doesn't get the girl but
that's not really the point the point
nay the Triumph of this moment is that
he asked her out as himself who he truly
is and in the end allowed himself to
feel all the emotions that come with
that brave decision initially I wasn't
too warm on this tubomy character but
after this climax after her waiting
specifically for him despite all that
was going on I think it's clear to me at
least what mob likes about her now and
if nothing else in those closing moments
of the story I'm glad that they are
still in touch building their
relationship the right way at the
beginning of this video I thought season
2's climax was a fitting way to end the
series on a high and I was scared that
there would be enough satisfying story
in season 3 to conclude this series in a
fashion that would feel overshadowed by
that climax in the prior season in
hindsight this is honestly laughable and
for the first time in my life I'm
standing before an anime and I'm
struggling to think of a way to describe
it that isn't simply perfect but I will
try to contend against my final thoughts
and wrap up this section
going into this series much the same way
I went into one piece JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure Hunter Hunter and many others
like them I was expecting to enjoy
myself and having began this series with
an idea of what the author one has to
offer I was expecting a great deal of
emotional resonance with an intensely
competent direction for each character
involved that delivers a humorous yet
emotionally fulfilling tale of Good and
Evil but I didn't quite understand what
I was getting myself into entirely while
mob psycho is all of that the flashy
animation the dramatic moments rich with
emotion and armed with a soundtrack that
Echoes throughout the story in equal
parts awesome and ambient there's
something more to this series that
honestly captured my heart in a way no
other Series has it's as if while
reading or watching the story one knew
something deeply personal about my life
my history my traumas my highs and my
lows and delivered this story to reach
someone like me with a complicated yet
clear message that encourages all of us
to be true to and love what makes us we
are and that it's the desire to accept
yourself and that drive to make
ourselves better people that determines
who we really are at the end of the day
but in truth this story isn't about me
it's not even necessarily about mob
himself it's a story about
self-acceptance about growth and all the
mental barriers otherworldly or
otherwise we build up internally that
helps us feel a level of comfort one
that affords us the opportunity not to
look at our ugly Parts the parts people
have rejected us for the parts that
deeply upset us that we try to pretend
never even really existed and so we grow
up continuing to lie to ourselves and
for some of us we never tell ourselves
that truth that we are okay just the way
we are that we're not broken if there's
one thing that I'm taking away from this
series as a whole it's that one is a
once in a generation type of artist and
writer someone that threw the medium he
chose managed to distill down and
communicate what is in actuality a
surprisingly complicated issue without
making its own trite or condescending
growth it's hard self-care is hard and
one knows that my favorite quote from
him is still from this interview when he
was asked what mob psycho 100 was about
and he said what I have in mind is to
tell a story of one little step I don't
believe our lives change completely for
the better at a short notice it's all
the small progress we make that's
important that's what I think of while
drawing this manga a story of one little
step I don't rate things out of 10 on
this channel but Bob psycho 100 is
unequivocally and without an ounce of
reservation from me a clear and emphatic
10 out of 10 Story one that I believe
needs to be seen by any young kid that's
struggling to accept who they are and
just needs that little bit of
encouragement to find the strength
within and take that one little step
I've been told you're not Mark thanks
for watching
[Music]
thank you